welcome to this video playing the
Templar assassin that's great I've got
three games against MN three losses
sounds brilliant charmila arsalan off ok
hello robots laugh pet lines
hmm Kim I don't have a good recipe
against then let's play the slowest line
don't think it gives wide much but
that's the general problem with this
laughs with white and you don't get much
Queen 86 and nowadays some it's pretty
common knowledge that black shouldn't
take on b3 okay look see one maybe
normal moves yeah maybe 96 now huh I
guess he gets tough iterated yeah that's
really nothing just going to double on
the D file and getting out of that
pinning situation okay it's just very
very equal
maybe he's trying to play like age 65
years own taking on d5 is something you
don't want to do really ng4 also not not
really great MMH how is going to take is
threatening g5
should takes d5 is really awkward it's
difficult to not do it okay
need some place that 1g three for the
bishop yeah i mean i'm not i'm not worse
but it is some bishop d5 is somewhat
somewhat poor kind of move every night
it's not not nothin you really want to
play but i didn't see anything else g5
was threatened with the piece trap they
couldn't go G for now f5 i have king of
three it's not a big deal ok oopsie too
yeah I guess yeah that's really it is
just completely equal now
you
check
yeah not not not that much to not that
much to to commentate so really not much
happening reading before now it's a
little little threat
and ok some trim wondering if I can just
enter yeah I think I'm can and should do
that some activity wouldn't hurt um rope
g8 or can also just take that's ready we
should be three ruby three you irritated
me a moment but doesn't work
DRA offered
hmm ok yo he Jackie declined to draw him
I don't know I mean
you know I mean if anybody is better
sorry it's me with those pawns but of
course it's a draw don't want to claim
anything here so may I cannot get to see
for check
too much kind of do much really check I
mean in terms of activity self pin hmm
time morning check check
but still nothing going on can go 25 or
whatever
it's going to see seven then or what
I slightly head on the crochet
DRA offered no no check check brass
cannot counter useless IAM game drawn to
do anything yeah I've a system just very
very Jewish nothing happening cheer
somehow I didn't get anything out of
that opening here got bit too many
pieces traded for wider to to do
anything and after here yeah Bishop b5
is as I said it's not exactly happy move
but II texts are kicking go eat eggs ah
oh I'm playing badly today you can just
do that my bishop yeah you know it's
just trapped very bad game arab g570
yeah i think there's never anything
going on check just just to draw all
along check check yeah maybe shy maybe
there's some some moment we're just some
of us blundered but chatting I don't see
it now it's probably just a draw but the
very bad badly played opening it could
have played that you takes d5 basically
winning a piece them what okay thanks
for watching